Belarus has confirmed
Russia has begun transferring
tactical nuclear weapons to Belarus.
And territory.
Ukraine's northern neighbor
has been Moscow's closest
ally since this war began last February,
when Russia invaded.
Russia has repeatedly used Belarus
as a staging ground for incursions
into Ukraine,
Russia and Belarus,
and defense ministers
signed the agreement on Thursday
to deploy the tactical nuclear weapons.
Opposition leaders
in Belarus denounced the move,
and the US government says
nature is not changing
its defensive posture.
Experts say
the move isn't only dangerous.
It's against the law.
It's illegal.
This violates
several international agreements,
including BELT that Belarus has signed,
including the Nuclear
Nonproliferation Treaty,
where it says
it will be a non-nuclear
state will not possess nuclear weapons.
It violates the
Budapest Memorandum of 1994
when Belarus gave up the Soviet
nuclear weapons
that have been stationed there.
It it violates the Belarus constitution.
It violates
Putin's own statements
of just two months ago when with China
he declared that no nation should station
nuclear weapons
outside their own territory.
Here he is doing that.
Meanwhile, we are getting
reports of a new wave of Russian strikes
on Ukraine that pummeled the country.
How is Overnight,
Sam has been looking about
what can you tell us, Alma?
So a massive wave of attack,
drones and missiles
coming overnight that hit Kharkiv.
They hit Dnipro. They hit Kiev.
The Ukrainian air force saying 17 cruise
missiles in 31 attack drones.
One official engineer wrote,
describing it
as an extremely difficult night,
saying that this lasted for hours.
It was extremely loud.
There was damage to buildings.
We don't know of any casualties
so far or injuries.
But put this in the context
of course,
of this expected counteroffensive.
And you begin to understand
everything that Ukraine
is juggling
from attacks
to civilian areas
all the way across the country.
To of course,
there's very difficult battles
along those front lines.
And of course, recently, Bermuda
mostly lost to Russia.
Ukraine insists
that it does have pockets of resistance
but again, on the back foot
in Bermuda, on those front lines
and dealing with a massive barrage
of missiles and drone attacks,
Washington has stated publicly
since last summer that they believe
Iran is supplying Russia with drones
to aid their invasion of Ukraine.
You've been investigating this
because it is a claim denied
vehemently by Iran Yes.
So those drone attacks
that happened last night
and many of the drone attacks
we've seen over the last weeks
and months,
those drones are Iranian made,
according to Ukrainian officials.
We as journalists have seen our teams on
the ground have seen the remnants
of these Iranian made drones.
The question is,
how are they getting there? Take a look
These calm waters are home
to a secret
Russia doesn't want you to know.
Experts say
Iran is quietly sending weapons on ships
like this one across the Caspian Sea
to replenish arms
for Moscow's war on Ukraine.
Concealing movement
at sea is considered
nefarious and potentially a violation
of international law.
But in the Caspian Sea,
there's a growing number of gaps
in vessels tracking data known as this,
with a more than 50% increase in ships
hiding their movement
between August and September of 2022,
according to maritime trafficking data.
Most of the vessels
going dark are Iranian
or Russian flag tankers to Russia, where
the timing is suspicious
to this practice.
Picking up last summer,
just as White House
officials revealed
that Russia had purchased
hundreds of drones from Iran.
So why would these ships want to hide
their movements?
Maritime security analyst
Martin Kelly tells us
it is
likely because
of what these vessels are carrying.
There's a correlation between Russia
requesting drones from Iran,
doc port
calls in the Caspian Sea
and an increase in activity.
And that to me was a key indicator
of these three aspects combined
that that something was going
on, probably the export of Iranian drones
from Russia.
This heat map from Lloyd's List
shows where most of those gaps in air
are concentrated,
mostly near Iran's
Mirabaud Port and Russia's
Astrakhan port,
where ships
appear to be turning
off their data on approach
and going dark
for extended periods of time.
Now, using data like this
and expert
analysis, CNN was able to identify
eight vessels
that exhibited suspicious behavior
in the Caspian Sea.
This is one such vessel.
It's a Russian flag tanker
that was seen in early January,
leaving Iran's a mirror bad port,
making its way across the Caspian Sea
to Russia's Astrakhan port.
Now, we cannot independently verify
what this tanker was carrying,
but experts tell us
the shipment was likely linked
to the arms trade.
And there
are signs that Tehran could be
ere mailing arms to the U.S.
and Ukraine,
both accused
Tehran of sending supplies to Russia
by plane.
CNN analyzed the tracking data
of four Iranian cargo planes
flagged by the U.S.
Commerce Department
for potentially carrying drone shipments.
Collectively, the aircraft
made at least 85 trips to Moscow airports
between May 2022 and March 2023
Iran has admitted
that it saw
a small number of drones to Russia,
but it says the SEAL
was a few months
prior to the war in Ukraine.
CNN has reached out
to Iran and Russia for comment,
but has yet to receive a response.
But given the much larger
volume, cargo ships can carry,
the Caspian Sea corridor
is likely the primary conduit.
And experts say it is the new frontier
for weapons trade between Moscow
and Tehran.
Tucked away from Western interference,
it provides an easy
avenue for sanctions evasion.
Expert Anisa
Tabrizi says
I think the perception in Moscow
is that Iran can teach a lot
to Moscow about how to go
and how to
still have a significant economy.
Even when sanctions are imposed.
And there is very little.
The U.S.
and its allies can do to stop it.
And more could be on the way.
Intelligence officials
warned in November,
Iran plans to send ballistic
missiles, ammunition
and more sophisticated drones to Moscow,
a bustling corridor potentially providing
a much needed arsenal.
Critical to Russia's land grab
in Ukraine.
Now, you
can't underestimate
the impact of these Iranian
made drones on the conflict.
They are small.
They are difficult to be detected
by the air
defense technology that Ukraine has.
They can cause a great deal of damage.
They frustrate
Ukraine at a time
when it's trying
to fight on those front lines.
And as you heard there,
the concern is, is
that Iran could provide more
than just drones.
This relationship
between Moscow and Tehran is deepening.
The cooperation is becoming
more and more important
as Russia turns to Iran for help
to replenish its arsenal.
Of course, on those front lines.
Iran sees an opportunity here
to rebalance
if you will, its relationship
with Moscow, experts tell us.
And the key thing here to remember
is the Caspian Sea.
Just take a look at that map.
The US doesn't have a footprint there.
Neato. Doesn't have a footprint there.
It is extremely difficult
for Ukraine's
western allies to stop this, if at all.
Okay, Salma,
thank you very much
indeed for bringing us that
great reporting.